the sign for vivos our card system
Montes current says everyone knows that
a VW bus is perfectly suited to
transport heavy cumbersome objects that
the model can also be perfectly suited
to drive through rugged terrain may not
be as well known but that's why
Volkswagens commercial vehicles division
as the VW t6 rockton in its programs
hawked on the rockton is designed for
Rough Country all-wheel drive and a body
raised by 3 centimeters is standard
off-road capability can be increased
with an optional engine underride guard
the wheelbase is especially short just
three meters my mind you might not
expect a VW Transporter to manage
terrain like this at all says Montes but
the rockton will clearly change your
mind look at how it takes as muddy road
as if it were a normal paved Street
Matis is really impressed I was very
design the foliage no mala asphalt here
to Strasse this is Sean Buckley or does
it's good the emphasis in the rockin is
all on utility it rolls on four steel
wheel rims that seem to be able to take
almost any terrain in stride the focus
on utility is evident in the interior as
well seats are upholstered with a robust
textile optional floor rails let them
slide back and forth back I fear many
things show that the rockin is
single-mindedly conceived for difficult
off-road uses montes take the seat
upholstery when you come in from the
woods with dirty clothes and muddy them
up they're easy to wipe off he says one
quart is under the hood a 2 litre 110
kilowatt ingénue consumes an average of
six-point-six litres of diesel in 100
kilometers according to the manufacturer
the rockton only comes with
all-wheel-drive and a 6 gear manual
transmission its maximum permissible
loaded weight is 3.2 tons the van cost
45,000 year
was in Germany
I'm hooked on doctor says the rock tunes
all-wheel-drive is powered through a
multi-plate clutch so the power is
always divided 50/50 between the front
and rear axles in front an electronic
differential lock brakes the bus to help
take it out of difficult situations
that's like I was treating fuzzy to a
theorem vid I have how Scott the VW t6
transporter rockin is the VW bus
currently most deserving of the
all-terrain title its performance off
pavement is very persuasive time to test
the VW t6 multi van panamericana where
the t6 transporter rock and is rough and
ready
the panamericana offers more comfort
the undecideds the Panamera Connor
differs from the rockin with its finer
furnishings and from the normal multi
van with its standard four motion
all-wheel drive as well as with a few
interior and exterior details as Montes
if you don't like being so close to the
ground you can also choose a ground
clearance that is two centimetres higher
[Music]
17 inch light metal wheels are standard
equipment on the van
under ride protection in front and back
is really only for looks but the
passenger area can be optionally
equipped with corrugated aluminum plate
the seats are especially elegant and the
Vans appearance is impressive this is
the most stylish way to pursue the call
of the wild as VW puts it our test
vehicles 2 litre 150 kilowatt TDI engine
can hit a top speed of 199 kilometers an
hour fuel consumption is 6.7 liters for
100 kilometers the elegant bus is
available in Germany starting at around
60,000 euros
[Applause]
[Music]
Allisyn island all analysis mattes the
multi van Panamericana offers much more
comfort than the t6 transporter rockton
all its bells and whistles are on a
completely different level but it won't
take you over rough terrain to buses
with two different characters the
rockton a reliable off-road specialist
and the Panamericana a stylish companion
where they're going isn't quite so tough
[Music]